You know I wish there was a
way that i could let her know
that we won
we did it she knows
they both do very much in the kind of 10 to 15 percent
at one point there was going to be a tag where
you opened a sort of bodybag drawer and there was
the vision kevin kind of talked to me and said
i just i gotta pull the shot and i was like oh
because i really wanted that profit participation
you set the terms you can change them all right
then he called me up and said can you come
into the office and you know when the boss
calls you up and your contract's over and
he's called you into the office you kind
of know exactly what that's about and i thought
i was gonna get kicked off the case you know so
i went in and i didn't want anybody
to feel comfortable uncomfortable so i
said look it's been a great run and
i love you guys and no hard feelings
and they went wait are you quitting and I
went no aren't you firing me and they went nope.
and I went, oh yeah. Okay. And they went we gonna give you a tv show. And I went I'm in!
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new Wandavision avengers endgame post credits
scene for that deleted scene that paul bettany
just explained which pretty much explains what's
happening during Wandavision it completely
sets up the show so there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs and revelations here we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos i'm doing
videos for all the Wandavision episodes they'll be
nine total this season we're also doing the disney
plus giveaway all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite easter egg from
the show so far on the video careful for spoilers
for everything that's happened during Wandavision
so far if you haven't seen any of the episodes yet
but the big thing here is that elizabeth olsen and
paul bettany revealed that there was originally
going to be an avengers end game post credit scene
that's where they talk about a tag scene a post
credit scene setting up Wandavision episode one
in just the series in general where scarlet witch
after they have iron man's funeral scene and she's
talking to hawkeye about black widow and vision
being all said i think that they do know that
we won i think they do know out there somewhere
after the avengers all go their separate ways
back to their homes back to their families the
ones that do have families she goes to nick fury's
storage facility where the new sword agency has
taken all the most powerful and dangerous items
from the avengers vs thanos final battle scene
everything of interest everything that belonged
to the avengers is left over from the battle
like iron man's nano infinity gauntlet they're
not going to leave that lying around they're
going to lock that up somewhere tight all the
avengers old weapons their extra gear all of
iron man's extra suits because the avengers base
was destroyed so it doesn't exist there anymore
when it comes time for avengers 5 and nick fury
puts another team together they'll have a new base
somewhere else like the sword space station is a
good start because we're going to be dealing with
more galactic threats during marvel phase 4 marvel
phase 5. but just for reference they actually
didn't need to store any of thanos weapons his
parts or ships because there would have been a
lot of debris from thanos army as well a lot of
dangerous stuff they didn't need to pick up any
of his dangerous trash because that all got dusted
when iron man snapped the infinity gauntlet one
really easy way to clean up the battlefield or
at least half of the stuff from the battlefield
he didn't dust any of the avengers stuff and
nick fury's sword agency in the mcu is just a
little bit different from the comics they change
what the acronym means for sword on Wandavision
if you zoom in enhance and you read the logo on
the back of the beekeeper suit here technically
this isn't a beekeeper suit this is like a hazmat
suit that just changes into a beekeeper suit when
he crosses the threshold of the reality you also
see the sword logo on the screen of the person
that's watching all this play out i think this
is going to be darcy's character from the thor
movies but she's watching and monitoring what's
happening inside this reality and looking at it
as if it were an actual tv show because that's
how things are playing out inside the bubble like
she's literally sitting there watching nick at
night episodes starring scarlet witch and vision
in the townspeople there are actually real towns
people there that are being manipulated as part
of this reality you zoom in enhance on the acronym
logo here and it says sentient weapon observation
response division and vision is a sentient weapon
inside the mcu both metaphorically and literally
because he's a sentient machine with crazy
power levels so paul bettany is basically saying
to elizabeth olsen here i love the way she's
surprised by some of this too that what happened
before the events of Wandavision episode one
is basically scarlet witch sick with grief just
unable to handle it in declining mental health
gets the amazing wonderful idea that she'll just
take vision steal vision from sword and nick fury
the government just go find where they're storing
him in his body bag pull it out of a drawer
and just kind of walk off drive off with a dead
person next to her if you're not a big comic book
reader this is not abnormal for scarlet witch some
of the most seminal important scarlet witch comic
book stories are about what happens when she goes
a little bit crazy and that's what sort of leads
her into the house of m's storyline and her big no
more mutants very famous comic book line because
she just completely loses it so scarlet witch
hatches this plan probably with some help from
other characters like agatha harkness early theory
where she tries to reactivate vision after she
steals his body but because he doesn't have the
mind stone anymore and so much of his personality
was tied up in that they do the white vision comic
book easter eggs where he comes back but he's
this cold unfeeling robot version of himself who
doesn't really care about scarlet witch doesn't
remember falling in love with her or anything
about their relationship before thanos killed
him during avengers infinity war to take the mind
stone in the comics the reason why he came back
that way is because they didn't use wonder man's
brain patterns to give him his personality there
are a lot of wonder man easter eggs on Wandavision
so far i'll start pointing them out as we see
them in episodes but you look in the background
here of a lot of these behind the scenes shots and
you see wonder man plastered all over the place
nathan fillion actually played a version of
wonder man during guardians of the galaxy vol 2
but a lot of those scenes wound up on the cutting
room floor just because james gunn said they
didn't fit into the movie the way he wanted them
to so technically we do actually have a wonder man
inside the mcu and he's played by nathan fillion
but i'm not expecting nathan phillian to show up
on Wandavision so if we see a version of wonder
man on Wandavision it'll probably be somebody else
but within the context of Wandavision as this
is all sort of spinning up into the events of
episode one someone probably takes advantage of
scarlet witch's powers by telling her that she
can bring vision back her version of vision as
he was make him whole again if she creates this
alternate reality where she can use her reality
warping powers to make things exactly how she
wants them to be change anything she wants on the
fly as if she were a god there was this line of
dialogue during episode 2 right at the beginning
where they're practicing with a special box with
the mine stone design on the front that looks like
an infinity stone so it's basically like a version
of vision's box from avengers age of ultron the
box that he literally was created and came out of
when he's talking to scarlet witch he says
he's going to bring her back exactly as she
was before and she's like yes that's exactly what
we're trying to do as if she's sort of talking to
us the audience i'm trying to bring him back
exactly the way he was inside this reality
for i illusion vow to bring you back exactly as
you are well you're back to yourself and that's
all i care about there's also that scene later in
the episode during episode two where dottie starts
bleeding she had started to get into it with
scarlet witch saying i've heard things about you
and your husband bad things in in the context of
the episode i think that was more of a communism
reference like she's trying to accuse them of
being communist because this is cold war era when
this is happening during the 1960s but scarlet
witch misreads the situation and thinks that
she's actually trying to out her as being one of
the avengers and she knows what's really going on
with her manipulating this reality and she tries
to reassure dottie saying i don't know what you've
heard but i'm not trying to hurt anyone we're not
trying to hurt anyone here as if she knows what's
really going on inside this reality in early
theory agatha harkness here knows what's going
on because she clearly seems like she understands
everything isn't normal the way they write her
scenes in dialogue like she knows that scarlet
witch is literally and metaphorically the star
of the show quote unquote because agatha knows
this is an alternate reality playing out like a
sitcom tv based reality and jimmy wu the sword
agents who are calling out to her through the
radio this is jimmy woo's voice from ant-man of
the wasp he's an fbi agent but he sounds like he's
working with the sword agents they don't know that
she's the one that actually stole vision's body
and they're actually here at this site studying
all this monitoring all this because they think
that some marvel villain has stolen vision's body
and is holding scarlet witch hostage wanda who's
doing this to you like they think that she's
being held against her will when really scarlet
witch is the one doing a lot of this herself but
is such a huge leap from her going in avengers
end game crushing thanos with her telekinesis and
energy blasts to creating a full-blown house of m
alternate reality in the mcu the mcu's version
of a house of m story that there probably had
to be somebody or multiple other entities that
helped her do this or gave her the idea that
she could do it and that's probably where agatha
harkness and her mystery husband ralph that she
keeps referring to come in i know everybody has
their mephisto theories there have been a lot of
mephisto easter eggs on the series so far ralph is
one of the nicknames that mephisto goes by in the
comics and i believe that ralph is also the name
used to refer to the devil during the lord of the
flies book that's a story where a bunch of kids
get trapped on an isolated island by themselves
and have to survive in dottie in the townspeople
during episode 2 keep referring to children like
they say for the children when you notice there's
actually no children anywhere in the town at
least not until scarlet witch gets pregnant
support west view elementary for the children
yeah it's totally not creepy when they
all say it in unison like that together
so early theory scarlet witch is the one in
control of this house of m reality the star
of the show but agatha harkness and whoever
she's working with mephisto or someone else
may be the main villain of doctor strange too
maybe that's nightmare maybe it's someone else
some major marvel cosmic villain they're
using scarlet witch manipulating her
to use her powers to meet their own ends everyone
posts all your theories about how scarlet witch
took vision's body in the comments below and in
related marvel news marvel just dropped a new
trailer with tom holland's spider-man i'll explain
what's going on during that there's a whole bunch
of bonus content in my Wandavision episode 3
video we'll post on friday just like normal
so make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any of those videos
and i'll just keep doing the disney plus giveaway
and all my Wandavision episodes everyone click
here for my full Wandavision episode 1 and
episode 2 video and click here for the boys
season 3 teaser trailer with jensen ackles
and learn about the big herogasm announcement
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!